my heroes were actually the great
dinosaur hunters of the American Museum
Roy Chapman Andrews Granger and those
guys Sagan is certainly a hero I have a
lot of heroes within my own disciplines
that are probably too arcane but Stephen
Jay Gould was perhaps my greatest hero I
knew him very well I knew him well
enough that I got in trouble a lot with
him he sort of viewed me as his
cantankerous younger brother he once
told me Peter you'll never be great but
you're pretty good now that that's quite
a slap in the face right we all want to
be great but it was from Steve say yeah
I'm great and you're not as great as me
but but I like the fact that you're
doing good work and it was that sort of
relationship okay but I miss him I miss
his voice he was the greatest single
public speaker I've ever ever heard he
was also the smartest man I've ever
known I've known quite a few intelligent
people but he was his processing speed
was beyond belief that's a great voice
lost